certains cadeaux via un petit cadeau
c'est pour kelly a pas pouvoir
kelly c'est de la part de gad
voilà où on attendait on va voir ce que
ces gars là c'est gad elmaleh gad
elmaleh c'est un un cadeau de cannes
exactement voyez un petit mot dedans je
me suis permis de l'écrire moi quoi mais
sinon aucun cadeau et de gaz
regardez ce que donnait ce cadeau c'est
pas moi mais j'avais un petit goûter non
je peux lire le petit beau petit mot a
dit le petit mot bien sûr c'est un vrai
cadeau non non ça palais alors pour une
djette si jolie il fallait bien une
fragrance empreinte de patchouli tué à
mon coeur ce que le poulet est au tajine
à moins que je devienne ta merguez qui
mariera sera encore de brains ah la la
ouais ben dhaen al malik camille ça va
ça vous dérange pas je vais pas besoin
de cadeau pour lui offrir mon coeur au
quotidien